[Musique]
le travail de ses entraîneurs a été mis
sur pause mais pas leur désir de bouger
et de faire bouger des former un groupe
privé sur facebook
et puis on était certes au début je
donnais des cours de zumba parce que
c'est ma passion
les entraînements sont gratuits en
quelques jours elle a reçu des dizaines
de demandes et des amis quand même
d'autres amis où j'apprends à notre
plein monde
j'ai du monde l'allemagne des des gens
des états unis on a tous les deux élus a
fermé nos entreprises c'est sûr qu'il ya
des pertes et monétaire mais si c'était
même pas pour essayer de regagner à ce
niveau-là ce procès de garder nos gens
actifs le groupe de cardio boxe d'ariane
et d'antonin sur facebook compte
maintenant plus de 1800 membres
bonjour tout le monde on est prêts pour
notre entraînement toujours dans une
cinquantaine de parcs au québec cardio
plein air a dû mettre à pied près de 400
entraîneur on a à peu près 60 gros clubs
par semaines qui viennent s'entraîner
ici au parc et le bain on se retourne
vers le virtuel justement et ont créé
une vidéo d'entraînement qu'on pose sur
facebook cardio plein air à tous les
jours à 8 heures donc les gens peuvent
le faire en direct avec nous à ce moment
là ou bien le faire à n'importe quel
moment de la journée
une planche de salut pour claudine
chênevert d'avoir la chance de pouvoir
se libérer l'esprit
ça fait du bien de ce que je veux faire
en fait c'est aplanir la courbe
d'inquiétude et d'anxiété et on sait que
l'activité physique - on dit que ça fait
un bien énorme plus que seulement
entraînement l'espèce de communauté
qu'on a créé en ligne surpris de leur
succès en ligne ses entraîneurs ils
trouvent une motivation est quelque
chose de gratifiant
en ces temps difficiles dans cette crise
doit vraiment lève le matin ça va bien
tu que ton compte qui pète le feu
après ça te regarde les nouvelles
options qui dorment ça vaut mieux
au moins chez que je fais bouger
d'autres personnes je sais que je le
rate
positif dans leur journée ici à nourrice
despatie radio-canada longue